Hey everyone, it's Mike from Morflows
here and welcome to today's video. We're
going to talk about reversals and
reversal trading to me is an important
thing for traders to understand in the
market because really, you know,
reversals I think give traders the best
opportunity to capture uh major moves of
the day. You know, it's only the
reversal trading a reversal that gives
you the opportunity to literally catch a
move from the high down to the low or
from the low up to the high and beyond,
right? Um you know everyone says uh ride
you know jump on the trend trend is your
friend but really you know a trend
starts at a reversal. All right and you
know that's where understanding the
order flow I think is going to come in
handy because um you know orderflow
allows you to look quote under the hood
right of the market and see the actual
buying and selling pressure uh taking
place which gives you early clues about
potential reversals. Okay. So, you know,
as opposed to just looking at simple uh
price candles, right, the simple
candlestick charts, you know, orderflow
looks at the volume of trades occurring
at each specific price level,
distinguishing between the aggressive
buying, you know, the people that are
lifting the offer with the market orders
versus aggressive selling, you know, the
people that are selling at the market,
the traders that are hitting the bid,
taking out the next bid. Okay? And you
know, on a footprint, you can see where
that is taking place.
Now, like I said earlier, um you know,
spotting a reversal. How can you spot it
in the order flow? Well, there's several
ways, right? Um the main one way is uh
you know, decreasing momentum with high
volume. So, as a trend progresses, say
um you know, as the market is going up,
uh you see price continue to make new
highs, but the volume of aggressive
buying needs to push it higher is
starting to diminish. Okay? And you know
sometimes you might see a lot of volume
trade at the top but price struggles to
further advance. And today you know in
the NASDAQ was a good example right we
uh you know we rallied up we had nice
healthy buying going into these new
highs. Uh this high here we started to
struggle went sideways. Looked like
we're about to sell off. Made a new high
by about uh four or five ticks. Um some
selling pressure came in. Market looked
like again it was about to sell off.
Then we just poked up here. made a new
high on again on healthy volume you know
1 1500 on this high uh back here we had
you know 500 700 in these two bars uh
earlier we had a th00and here when the
normal volume is around 400 uh you know
contracts more or less you know that's
an average over these bars um and then
finally you know we we started to sell
off nicely from this this high up here
and actually we sold off all the way
down into new lows. All right. So when
you start seeing right the the these new
highs being made on on heavy volume but
price struggles to advance further. This
could indicate that buyers who are
driving the trend are running out of
steam or no longer willing to chase
price higher, right? I mean because
what's causing price to go higher is
that aggressive buying. People lifting
the offer, clearing that offer out,
lifting the next offer, clearing that
out. Finally, you get all the way up
here. You see these this one big order
it looks like just went through here.
How do I know it's one order is because
there's a lot of zeros uh coming in
here. All right. And then um you know
another way you could uh spot a reversal
is maybe there's some absorption taking
place, right? And absorption is a key
concept in orderflow analysis. You know
as a market again tries to push higher
you might see large sell orders, limit
orders um absorbing all the aggressive
buying at certain price levels. Now this
is a NASDAQ chart and honestly I don't
really talk about NASDAQ very much but
you know in markets like uh interest
rates you know bonds tens um you tend to
see the absorption more because the
volume is more concentrated at price
levels here NASDAQ it tends to be spread
out um so I don't really for me it's a
little bit harder to see the absorption
simply because of the volatility in the
market of the NASDAQ um where price has
to move a distance in order to you know
run into some uh what I would consider
absorb absorption. Okay. But, you know,
if this was treasuries, you know, I'd be
looking for heavy volumes, you know,
sort of up near the high. All right. So,
once
the what sort of, you know, once we hit
a high, you know, same would be true if
it was a low, if you're looking for the
market to rally, but it would just be in
the opposite terms, then you got to look
for strong counter moves. Okay? Okay. So
after the you know the decreasing
momentum with high volume um you know
you you tend to start seeing um signs
that the other side of the market is
stepping in with conviction. Okay. So um
you know so if you hit a high you might
see sharp increase in aggressive
selling at or near the highs. Doesn't
necessarily have to be right at the
high. It often comes in after the high
is made because after you make the high,
what you want to see is, you know,
traders sort of sit up and say, "Oh
we made a high." This is a good
place to sell, right? So, it's not going
to be as you're making that high. Often
it comes in just after the high is made.
Um, so then you often see a sharp
increase in aggressive selling volume at
or near these highs. Price starts to
move down and selling pressure is
sustained, indicating sellers are now
taking control. And you know, sort of
the reason why I wanted to make this
video is because I I you know, I have an
indicator for sale. It's called the V
reversal. V V stands for why why is it a
V reversal? Um Baltos reversal or you
know the V for um you know I love V
reversals in the market. But today was
was very interesting in the NASDAQ. Um,
just on the orderflow chart, you can see
up here when we made that final high up
here at
1057, you're starting see the signs of a
reversal taking place and this market
really sold off down to the lows. Now,
we did have one sign here of a potential
reversal. It just didn't pan out.
Another one came in here, traded back up
into it before you made that final high
up here, and then the market sold off.
Now, what was interesting is because
earlier in the day after the cash
opened, you know, we were selling off
after the cash opened. Let me just get
back here to the cash open. Um, you
know, 8:30 right here is the cash open.
So, we're sort of drifting down. Little
sell signal came in a buy that didn't go
anywhere. Then another sell down into
these lows, right? And once we made
these lows here, okay, there started
being signs in the order flow of a
potential reversal. Okay, and again, you
know,
NASDAQ is kind of a unique market in the
sense that volatility is unlike uh that
that you'll see in interest rates or or
even some of the currencies most of the
time and you get some major moves. But
when I was looking at the bar chart this
morning, this is what I was looking at
here. So, just going back again. You
know, I I was writing an email about uh
the V reversal
indicator and you know how we started to
sell off a little bit, hit this low, and
we're just trading back into the low.
The low is holding once, twice, you
know, and again, doesn't look like much
of a move, but this from this area here,
you're talking about, you know, 721,
733, 734, 35, gets all the way up to
800, pulls back into that area where the
reversal was taking place. So, the
reversal, I already knew that it was
holding, right? Then we dip back down in
there and then we run up run up from you
know 7 again back up from around 740 all
the way up to 840. Another bullish
signal came in here. Came back down
tested it once twice. Rallied back all
the way up to new highs. Right again a
couple more bullish signals here all the
way up into these highs. This was that
little uh sell signal. Another sell
signal. Finally, you made that new high
up here at 9:34 and three/4ers before
you start getting what the sell signals
right for the bearish reversal coming
in. Right? You had one sign here,
another one
here. This first one immediately failed.
The second one just sort of went down a
little bit, tested it, came off, and it
just there was just some more buying
that had to get be exhausted before um
the market started selling off and then
sold off. This is from you know the the
9 what is we'll call it
9006 9007 area immediately sells all the
way down into you know the 820ish area
bounces up another sell signal comes
back in here at 840 hits 820 now it hits
this zone from earlier breaks through
that all the way down into new lows so I
mean look at this today it was
interesting right where can't make this
stuff up where it just rallies from the
low all the way up to the highs new
makes new highs sells off from the highs
back down into where into new lows right
that's why I say you know understanding
and having a way to trade the order
flow at reversals gives you that
opportunity for big moves now today was
unique in the sense that it went from
the low to the high back down to lows I
don't think we're going to go back up to
um new highs where now we're just sort
of hanging down here near the lows it's
around 2:00 but it went from the low all
the way up to the high and what is that
move right this move we're talking you
know theoretically 740 I'm not saying
that you would have bought it on the
lows but when the signals came in here
um you know we're trading around 33 733
740 all the way up into the 900s and
then from the 900s back down below 700
300 points up 300 points down there'll
buy
here people say well give you a sell
signal down here at the low Well, yeah,
that's your last one. That's the fifth
one here after 1 2 3 4 5 sixth one here.
Then you get the rally cuz remember,
right, if if you're looking
to trade a reversal, you need a move to
reverse. This is a little bit of a
pullback. That's why it's giving the
signal. But then we rally from 660
basically all the way up to seven, you
know, up into the 780s. Then it starts
giving more reversal signals coming in
here around the 780 area to what? Back
down into new lows down to 6, you know,
below 650, 640, 620 gets down here to
06. And again, I'm not saying you cover
it down here, but look at that from 780
down to 680. It's 100 points. We did
bounce up a little bit. Did give a buy
signal. And again, I I I'm not looking
for this move to all a sudden rally back
up to the highs. You know, at some
point, it's going to sort of peter out.
It's about 2:00 right now. Um, you know,
we're sitting on a couple of sell
signals here. But, you know, again, I
just thought it was kind of interesting
um today in the
NASDAQ. E- minis kind of started out
kind of similar. Um although in the E-
minis right off
the cash
open right selling came in selling 30
point move down
right again this is these are not shorts
you' take you should already be short
from up here again maybe you're not
interested in trading on the cash open
but 10 minutes after you got a sell
signal for 20
points then you get a buy signal here
okay this buy signal didn't work it it
failed I mean I wish every signal would
be uh bank, but it's
not bullish signal here. Pulls back into
that zone, keeps going. A couple bearish
signals, but then you get another
bullish signal here again. It's just
sort of working its way up. Then the
bearish signals come in here, stopped in
here, another bearish signal coming in
around the, you know, the mid, you know,
we'll call it 85 and down in here all
the way down into 65. Now, that's
another 20 point move. um some bullish
signals coming in here around 12. Again,
these look like small moves, but you're
talking, you know, 78 all the way up to,
you know, almost 88. It's about a
10-point move. And then later around
1:00, another sell signal coming in
here, you know, around the 76
area down into the
50s back
up to sort of where we are right now.
So, again, you just it's just
interesting. I I was starting to write
an email for my users about the um V
reversal indicator. And just really
quick, this is using in the settings um
the quick trade setting.
Okay, because this is a short time
frame. It's a 30 second chart and I like
to use the quick trade setting on those
markets. All right, so thanks again. And
you know, again, if you're interested in
this indicator, I've made it available
outside of the order flows vault. So, it
is a standalone indicator for sale. I
got a special deal going on right now.
The link is in the description below.
But again, I I really just wanted to
make this video because I I I was
writing the long email out and every
time I look at the chart, it was just
giving me something more to write about
and I just thought it'd be easier for me
to create a video on it. So, thanks
again everyone and I'll see you guys
later. Bye-bye.